BACK FROM THE NFC ON THAT
REQUEST FROM FRIDAY.
>> THANKS.
>> Bret: THERE’S A HANDFUL OF
SENATORS CONSIDERING ACQUIT AND
ONE IS SENATOR JOE MANCHIN.
THANKS FOR THE TIME.
WE KNOW YOU HAVE TO GET SOME
DINNER.
I DON’T WANT TO KEEP YOU TOO
LONG.
WHAT DID YOU LEARN TODAY, IF
ANYTHING.
YOU ASKED A QUESTION TODAY.
DID IT CHANGE YOUR OPINION ON
ANYTHING?
>> IT JUST GIVES US CLARITY.
THERE’S DISCREPANCIES THAT CAME
BACK.
THE FIRST TWO OR THREE DAYS IN
THE PROSECUTION AND FROM THE
DEFENSE OF THE PRESIDENT.
I THINK BOTH WERE COMPELLING.
BOTH WERE ARTICULATE AND
PRESENTED WELL BUT THERE WERE
SOME CONTRADICTIONS AND WE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE.
I THINK THE QUESTIONS BEING
ASKED ARE TO GIVE CLARITY TO
THAT.
TOMORROW SHOULD HELP IMMENSELY
AND WE’LL SEE WHERE WE GO AND
THE WITNESSES ARE A BIG THING.
I BELIEVE AND THAT THINK YOU
KNOW I FEEL WITNESSES ARE
NEEDED.
AND ALSO DOCUMENT ARE PERTAINING
TO THE CHARGES BROUGHT AGAINST
THE PRESIDENT BECAUSE AT ONE
TIME I HEARD THE PRESIDENT SAY
AND A GREED WITH HIM HE SAID I
DON’T THINK I CAN GET A FAIR
TRIAL OVER IN THE HOUSE.
I NEED A FAIR TRIAL AND I WANT
WITNESSES AND HE SHOULD GET A
FAIR TRIAL AND THE SENATE IS
WHERE THE TRIAL WOULD BE.
>> Bret: YOU KNOW OPENING THE
DOOR TO WITNESSES OPENS THE DOOR
TO REPUBLICANS CALLING
WITNESSES.
>> I WANT TO MAKE SURE I CLARIFY
THIS, THE CLARITY IS THE
REPUBLICANS HAVE A RIGHT TO CALL
WITNESSES.
IF THE DEMOCRATS CALLED TWO
WITNESSES SHOULDN’T REPUBLICANS
HAVE A RIGHT TO CALL TWO OR FOUR
THEY AGREE ON.
WHAT THEY MAY NOT AGREE ON THIS
PERSON IS NOT RELEVANT WHETHER
IT’S THE BIDENS OR SOMEBODY
ELSE.
YOU KNOW WHAT, MY OPINION WAS MY
OPINION BUT THERE SHOULD BE
NORTHBOUND AND I WOULD THINK
CHIEF JUSTICE ROBERTS IS THAT
PERSON WHEN THERE’S A
DISCREPANCY TO BE A WITNESS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE PERTINENT
INFORMATION THAT COULD
CONTRIBUTE TO WHETHER THE
PRESIDENT IS CONVICTED ON THE
TRUE ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT OR
ACQUITTED.
THAT’S ALL I HAVE SAID AND STILL
SAY.
>> Bret: IF THE VOTE COMES DOWN
AND REPUBLICANS MANAGE TO GET
THE VOTES TO PREVENT WITNESSES,
COULD YOU CONSIDER A VOTE TO
ACQUIT IN THAT SCENARIO?
>> IT’S JUST SO HARD TO HAVE A
FAIR TRIAL.
I’VE NEVER BEEN A JUROR OR BEEN
CALLED TO JURY DUTY IN MY ENTIRE
LIFE.
THIS IS SOMETHING NEW TO ME AND
IT’S FASCINATING AND I TAKE IT
SERIOUS.
THEY’RE SERIOUS CHARGE.
>> Bret: YOU COULD CONSIDER --
>> I HAVE EVERYTHING OPEN.
I HAVE NOT MADE MY MIND UP.
I’M IMPARTIAL AND WANT TO WAIT
UNTIL THE WHOLE PROCESS IS OVER.
>> Bret: WHY YOU COME FROM, WEST
VIRGINIA SEEMS TO BE MAKE ITS
MIND UP.
BACK IN 2016 VOTED FOR PRESIDENT
TRUMP BY ABOUT 70% AND THE
RECENT POLLS ON I AMMPEACHING AN
REMOVING THE PRESIDENT IS ABOUT
THE SAME AND 20% OF WEST
VIRGINIANS COULD YOU CONVICT THE
PRESIDENT AND LOOK AT YOUR
CONSTITUENTS AND SAY I  -- YOU
HAVE A VOTE IN NINE MONTHS BUT
IT’S SO EGREGIOUS WE HAVE TO
KICK HIM OUT NOW.
>> I’VE BEEN IN WEST VIRGINIA A
LONG TIME AND BEEN ELECTED TO
MANY POSITIONS IN THIS GREAT
STATE AND THERE’S WONDERFUL
PEOPLE IN WEST VIRGINIA AND A
GOVERNOR FOR TWO TERMS AND THEY
EXPECT ME TO DO WHAT’S FAIR AND
RIGHT AND I HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
GO HOME AND EXPLAIN IT.
IF I CAN’T EXPLAIN IT I CAN’T
VOTE FOR IT.
THAT’S WHY I’VE BEEN WAITING TO
SEE ALL THE EVIDENCE.
I HAVEN’T BEEN QUICK TO
JUDGMENT.
ANYONE WHO’S PREJUDGE THE
PRESIDENT ONE WAY OR ANOTHER AND
EVERYBODY IS INNOCENT UNTIL
PROVEN GUILTY AND THAT’S THE
RULE OF LAW.
>> I UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE A
COUPLE MORE DAYS HERE.
REPUBLICANS SAY ONE, THE AID WAS
RELEASED AND FLOWED OUT ON TIME.
TWO, THERE WAS A MEETING AT THE
U.N. WITH THE PRESIDENT OF
UKRAINE.
NO ANNOUNCEMENTS WERE MADE ON
THE INVESTIGATIONS OF THE BIDENS
AND BURISMA AND THE UKRAINIAN
PRESIDENT SAID THEY DIDN’T FEEL
PRESSURE AND INFORMATION THE
PRESENTATIONS YOU’VE SEEN TO
FAR, IF YOU GET TO FRIDAY AND
THERE ARE NO WITNESSES
CONSIDERING THOSE STIPULATIONS
CAN YOU VOTE --
>> LET ME GIVE YOU ONE MORE
SCENARIO, BRET.
AND THEY’RE FIGHTING RUSSIAN
GRESSION.
HAVE YOU A PRESIDENT WITH NO
POLITICAL EXPERIENCE WHATSOEVER
COMING IN.
THAT PERSON COMES IN, ZELENSKY
AND BASICALLY HE’S TALKING TO
THE SUPER POWER IN THE WORLD THE
MOST POWERFUL PERSON AND SURE
HE’S NEEDING THIS AND 2017 AND
2018 THAT WAS CLEAR HE GAVE THEM
JAVELIN WEAPONS TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES.
THEN THE ASSERTION HAS BEEN MADE
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE WE UNCOVER
EVERY STONE.
YOU CANNOT BE INVOLVED.
WE CANNOT ALLOW FOREIGN ENEMIES
TO BE INVOLVED.
THAT’S OPPOSED TO WHO WE ARE AS
A COUNTRY.
>> Bret: AND TO WHAT HAPPENED
AND CAN YOU TURN TO WEST
VIRGINIANS SAYING I KNOW THIS
DIDN’T HAPPEN BUT BECAUSE OF HOW
DEMOCRATS PRESENTED IT WE NEED
TO KICK HIM OUT OF OFFICE NINE
MONTHS BEFORE ELECTION.
>> NO ONE SHOULD BE KICKED OUT
OF OFFICE UNLESS THE CHARGES ARE
ABSOLUTELY FACTUAL.
SHOULD WE JUST SAY THE SAME
THING AS WHAT McCONNEL HAD SAID.
IT’S ONE YEAR, WHY SHOULD WE DO
ANYTHING.
>> Bret: DO YOU HAVE ANY
CONCERNS WITH THE WHISTLEBLOWER
AND THE CONTACTS WITH THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE?
ADAM SCHIFF SAID AGAIN TODAY HE
DOESN’T KNOW WHO THE
WHISTLEBLOWER IS.
>> I TRY TO TRUST THE PEOPLE
THAT I WORK WITH.
IF THEY LIED TO ME ONCE, THEN
SHAME ON ALL OF US BECAUSE I’D
NEVER BELIEVE THEM AGAIN.
IF THEY’RE SAYING THEY DIDN’T
KNOW I BELIEVE THEY’RE TELLING
THE TRUTH.
IF THEY’RE WILLING TO DO IT
UNDER OATH IT TELLS ME MORE.
IT IS WHAT IT IS RIGHT NOW.
WE’RE IN A HE SAID-SHE SAID AND
WHAT SIDE ARE YOU ON.
I’M A PROUD WEST VIRGINIA
DEMOCRAT BUT A MORE PROUD
AMERICAN AND I’M NOT GOING TO
MAKE A DECISION.
I WANT MY PRESIDENT TO SUCCEED
AND DO WELL AND I WANT TO LIVE
WITHIN THE LAW AND THEY’RE NOT
ABOVE THE LAW SO WE ALL HAVE TO
MAKE SURE WE’RE DOING EVERYTHING
BY THE LAW.
>> Bret: I TRIED TO GET TO
ANNOUNCE A COUPLE TIMES.
SENATOR WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
AND WE’LL GET YOU GET SOME
DINNER AND HEAD BACK IN.